first i had to make sure it was real
what is happening what's going on count
on the kardashian jenner family to pull
off the most
epic prank i was like crying laughing
chloe kim courtney kylie chris and
kendall all sat down together with some
intimidating looks
to hilariously facetime their famous
friends
just spontaneous just something fun so
what happens when you answer a call and
see all six
very rich and powerful women sitting
there in dead silence
well let's just say everyone was shook
[Music]
hey yeah that's chloe's boyfriend
tristan thompson who went from
excited to thinking he was getting an
intervention
stormy's dad travis scott wasn't having
it and literally peaced out
what's going on bye
tick tocker addison rey's face said it
all
hi dave chappelle literally had us dying
that's the best one justin bieber was
pretty much all of us
hey guys this is
what is happening jb's wife haley was
totally caught off guard
hello the model even commented on the
instagram post and wrote
i was shook we were laughing so hard
james charles was confused af
what is going on one of kim's best
friends lala anthony
looked like she was about to jump in the
shower until
hello david dobrik called the famous
family out
that's ridiculous so stupid funny tyler
the creator thought he was being punked
can you see me and actress jennifer
lawrence was
almost in tears first day i had to make
sure
it was real
if you remember jayla is a major
kardashian fan as she admitted on jimmy
kimmel i've been obsessed with you for a
really long time but can you remember
the first time we met
i do actually we were at the prank was
so good
the comment section was lit chrissy
teigen even revealed that she was going
to answer
but was busy in the ladies room the
kardashians are known to be the ultimate
pranksters
when we do these pranks we go we go all
in
head first remember when chloe straight
up transformed into chris to take some
fake
pap pictures oh hey chris
fire the saga continues yeah that's
chris
aka chloe stumbling in front of a liquor
store
and diving into a dumpster we're going
to get christy
our pr representative to leak the photos
we cannot wait
and it's safe to say mama chris was
mortified
who sent you that what do you mean you
don't know where that is mom come on
oh i just got another how about our
public urination
how could you not remember it i don't
know that's really scary
could you imagine another scenario
no like what in another world do you
ever think that maybe just like on our
spare time
i get a camera and your daughter gets
dressed up like you and we do
really weird things and look like kris
jenner wow
you